luffy's bounty will surpass roger at the
end of the story and i will prove it to
you with math honestly i've always found
bounties pretty irrelevant in one piece
until recently when i suddenly changed
my mind about them completely
bounties actually serve a number of
purposes in the story it's just that i
really hate eighty percent of the toxic
power scaling going on and a lot of
people that do that to bring up bounties
for their arguments so i guess by
default i got annoyed with the idea and
kind of threw it aside as a nice little
gadget oda introduced however i was
watching a really interesting goku on
pirates the other night when i couldn't
sleep and it sort of hit me that
bounties were a very real and important
thing heck still are in some places on
earth i mean i knew that but having it
presented in that way really helped me
change my mind hi my name is manu my
favorite bounty is the one filled with
coconut cream that's delicious and today
i'm gonna explain how bounties in one
piece work my personal prediction for
the straw hats final bounties and at the
end of this video i will show you how
luffy's bounties have helped to make
luffy the best shonen hero of all time a
bounty is actually a pretty smart system
in itself here's the deal imagine a
government that has a problem on a large
scale a problem so big and so common
that the government alone can't handle
it so what do they do they offer money
to anyone who is willing to help a
bounty then can be on people or animals
or really anything else and you can earn
money by locating capturing or killing
them in one piece the problem the
government is dealing with are pirates
because all pirates are evil and not
because they themselves [ __ ] over the
entire world oh but actually turns out
there is also bounties on
revolutionaries so in one piece whether
or not you get a bounty is not
determined by how dangerous you are to
the people but how dangerous you are to
the rule of the world government itself
i think one big mistake that some people
make not you i know but some people is
taking the bounty system as a system for
power scaling in other words the higher
the bounty the stronger the person
that's wrong sorry of course power plays
a role as well i'm not denying that
logically by becoming powerful you
potentially pose a bigger threat and
even pirates themselves expect a certain
level of power from someone with a high
bounty
however the fact that dragon is the most
wanted person in the world as i
explained in his analysis video is
because he's a powerful person actively
working to tear down the established
world order not because he's stronger
than kaido whitebeard probably right
right
yeah
right similarly before the time skip
kid's bounty was larger than luffy's
because he went around killing and
pillaging unlike luffy who's mostly just
hanging out and making friends wherever
he goes and oda actually confirmed this
in an sbs he also noted that within a
crew the captain's bounties always
increases more than the crew members
even if the power difference isn't that
big now there are a few very interesting
details to this bounty system obtaining
a bounty in the first place basically
means you are officially a criminal in
the government's eyes i think we rarely
think about this but these posters
actually say dead or alive which is
pretty wild no once you get a bounty
anyone i mean anyone can come and just
shoot you and it's completely legal
which is really [ __ ] up when you think
about examples like little robin who got
her bounty for being the last survivor
of o'hara
a little girl with no human rights if
you can call it human rights what the
world government is pretending to
protect and of course in just a bit
we'll look at robin's final bounty in
the story which you might found
surprising the bounty posters themselves
can be found in bars public places and
marine buildings basically they serve to
warn common citizens of dangerous
criminals deter those people from
entering a city and at the same time
incentivize bounty hunters such as soro
used to be to go after these people and
earn a living from turning them in or
killing them
and even though he never really
discussed it i'm pretty sure that oda
got inspired for this system from his
love for western the bounties on real
world pirates as well as the pictures of
wanted criminals in japanese police
stations whenever i see them they really
remind me a lot of those wanted posters
in one piece as well funnily enough
however even though bounties are
supposed to be something bad and deter
bad people from doing bad things in the
world of one piece where the government
is as corrupt hypocritical and unfair as
it gets pirates actually take a lot of
pride in their bounty
[Music]
it actually serves as a sort of proof of
achievement where they get their pirate
grades at the end of the school year and
so in general while this is portrayed in
a funny way most of the time as you well
know one piece also has a very dark
sub-tone and so for me the fact that
there are so many pirates in this world
forming their own societies and groups
shows us just how broken the world
system truly is i mean many of the
people we meet only became pirates
because all over the world people have
to live in desperation war and hardship
while the rich and powerful play gods
now however i want to give off my own
predictions for each of the straw hats
final bounties luckily i have a lot that
i can work with now that we finally know
some of the biggest bounties in the
story the largest bounty we know so far
belongs of course to the pirate king
himself
[Music]
that's about 5 million
which is a lot of money but enough to
risk your life against one of the
strongest people in the world
i'd probably pass and go for like i
don't know 50 buggies or something
by now we actually do know the bounty
for all the yonko as well as most of the
commanders and i think this already
gives us a pretty nice range of where
things are going to head however two
bounties that i wish i knew for this
task are that of dragon and rocks how
big is the bounty on the head of the
most wanted man in the world who plans
to topple the world governments and how
much for rox the captain of the most
notorious pirate crew but let's work
with what we get was the cup empty will
my bounty predictions be completely off
am i going to lose all sponsorships
because this transition is so weird find
out right after you subscribe you filthy
cowards but first a word from our
sponsor
oh and they're saying the rainforests
are dying who are you no i know we're in
japan but like i think this is taking
cultural appropriation a little bit too
far get into my apartment glad you asked
i am salesman manu you are live in your
own video right now and i have just the
thing for you this video is sponsored by
manscape.com they send us their
performance package for christmas that
has you covered from head to toe
christmas is literally over well
international shipping sucks here you go
the first thing my boy the lawnmower 4.0
it's a waterproof trimmer designed for
your sensitive areas with an extra led
so you can see where you go here are the
crop preserver and the crop reviver a
game changer deodorant and toner for
those two guys down there and this is
the wheat whacker for ear and nose hair
trimming but i don't even have and last
but not least the shears 2.0 luxury 6p
stainless steel nail kit and for a
limited time lonely you get this luxury
travel bag as well as manscape's
anti-shaving boxers as a gift on top so
go to manscape.com and use my promo code
o'hara to get 20 off plus free
international shipping now here are the
criteria for my bounties obviously when
making predictions like these you need
to make some assumptions personally i'm
guessing that there will be only one
last big bounty update in the story
overall after wano or latest after elbaf
the straw heads are about to free the
land of the samurai standing against two
yonko and they will come out of it as a
yonko crew themselves everything past
the time skip has led to this moment so
of course we need new bounties right
however other than roger who jumped to
the top by finding the one piece and
learning the true history i don't think
luffy and co will get another increase
after reaching love tale after all roger
was too early and had to prepare the
next generation
luffy meanwhile is the one who will
actually topple the current system and
make a world that is better for everyone
to live in with the big war at the end
of the story i don't think there will be
a lot of time for the government to make
new bounty posters and after that
government won't be there anymore the
second thing we will look at are
patterns and everyone's bounties and for
luffy in particular his bounties are
actually part of oda's storytelling and
the third one will obviously be me being
biased and just taking it the way i feel
would make sense so first chopper
i think the joke with chopper's bouncy
being ridiculously low is pretty funny
man i kind of want to see it until the
end however at the same time i think he
also deserves some recognition one
possible and pretty cool way around it
would be if chopper actually got two
bounties instead of one one normal one
super low and one for his monster point
form which we could put somewhere around
the 300 million mark a bounty that luffy
once had but still the lowest in the
crew i honestly think that all of the
straw hats will crack 300 million at
least next we have namita
as the navigator of the future pirate
king and with her increasing power nami
will get a solid boost for her final
bounty i think putting it somewhere
around 400 million would be pretty
reasonable the next spots however are a
bit trickier because everyone gets very
powerful from here
brooke is one of my favorite characters
and i believe he's heavily
underestimated in how dangerous he can
truly be but i still don't see him
getting far beyond nami in terms of his
bounty 420 seems like a reasonable
number don't you think
now even though frankie proves to us
over and over again how strong he truly
is and possibly still having the plans
of the pluton he is one of the straw
hats who gets very little recognition
from the governments i'll put him up
here with around 490 million berries
which is more than sasaki's 472 million
but less than our next candidates usual
usual has gotten this ridiculous 200
million barry bounty after dressrosa but
as we all know he is living up to his
ideal of becoming a brave warrior of the
sea more and more and since his pattern
seems to follow around round numbers
similar to luffy going from 30 to 200
500 million would be the perfect sweet
spot for him after wano more than
doubling his current one and following
in luffy's steps now we're really
getting into interesting territory here
kaikou no jinbe
okay so i'm actually going to put jimbei
in fifth place here he's a former
warlord and incredibly strong but not
quite zoro sanji luffy material
nonetheless jinbe might be very close to
that one billion mark he went from 76 to
250 to 438 which includes all numbers
except one and nine so why not
910 million berries
i mean even oda has made fun of the
bounties between these two nonetheless
zoro's role in the crew is a bit more
centered around combat and he is
technically the first mate while sanji
is also the cook and in general a bit
more personality based as a character
actually made two long videos about both
of them quite recently as well and
honestly i think both of them will
overcome king and queen and get bounties
higher than them technically being
commanders on a new emperor's ship i
think both will pass 1 billion berries
just a little bit apart i'd like zorro
to surpass luffy's current bounty so 1.5
billion plus 90 million for ashrada's
nine sword style sanji meanwhile i could
see somewhere around the 1.3 billion
mark plus maybe some 66 million for
accepting his germa heritage now if
you've paid attention have you been
paying attention you better have been
paying attention but then you will have
realized that before luffy there is
still one straw hat that is unaccounted
for
[Music]
i honestly have no idea whether oda
looks at this the same way as i do but i
personally would love to see robin's
bounties surpass zorro and sanji's of
course not because of her power but
because of who she is we already know
that the other yonko are trying to steal
her for her knowledge and abilities and
so is cp0 and so after wano once luffy
will shift his eyes towards love tale
robin will be the key to everything
you gotta know
the government knows this and will try
to stop it at any cost so i want robin
not only to be chased but to also get
the respect for that as well with a 2
billion barry bounty making her the most
wanted woman in the world after big
mom's defeat
and now finally we have luffy and
admittedly until now there wasn't too
much to go off of with the other straw
hats for luffy however bounties have
always played an important role which
makes it easier for me to predict his
final bounty at the end of the story for
that we have to look at the numbers of
luffy's bounty compared to the enemies
he's defeated and how the bounty system
overall keeps pushing luffy's unique
rise to power right into our faces let's
start in the east blue
sea
luffy's very first bounty are 30 million
berries after defeating buggy 15 million
kudo 60 million don creek 70 million and
arlong 20 million berries that's 150
percent of arlon's bounty and just so
you know luffy's bounties will keep
outgrowing his enemies at this same rate
and with this our protagonist is
presented as the strongest man in the
east blue what better way to set him up
as the hero and a real threat to the
governments the next increase is in
alabasta that is actually quite similar
to wano both are big sagas leading up to
a showdown with one of the most powerful
people in this part of the grand line
crocodile the warlords and kaido the
yonko both of whom have bounties far
exceeding luffys and seem to be
unbeatable for him at first crocodile
slokia vs kaido's conquerors haki and
both times luffy actually gets a glimpse
at that level beforehand with mihawk and
big mom but it's never really about
fighting on that level yet
after defeating crocodile who was frozen
at 81 million berries luffy triples his
bounty to 100 million over 120 of that
of his opponent establishing himself as
someone who can play on the warlord
level just as he will be able to compete
on the yonko level after wano
[Music]
is a bit different here the bounties are
all about the perceived threat to the
world government and not power in itself
that's why luffy's big enemy has no
bounty while his own triples to 300
million after declaring war on the
government itself the next one is maybe
the most curious one though after
defeating moria breaking in and out of
impul down and participating at the
marine fort war after all that stuff
luffy's bounty only increases to 400
million
you might also have felt like that was a
little bit too low however it
wonderfully shows us how oda uses
luffy's bounty to illustrate his
developments this is luffy's biggest
defeat in the story so far not being
able to save his crew or his brother and
so such an utter defeat would have felt
weird to us the audience with a
ridiculously high new bounty and so once
again after all that it is simply 125
percent of moria's bounty who was frozen
at 320
gave million another 100 million
bringing him to 500 million 166 percent
of that of caesars and 150 of dofie's it
was a really hard fight yes but both
arcs were only set up for wano and
taking down a yonko so taking down
another warlord was not as significant
as it was before the time skip even if
it was dofi a real curve ball in this
was then whole cake island the last
increase so far
luffy surpasses both cracker and
katakuri tripling his bounty to 150
percent of katakuri's one billion to one
point five billion this at first glance
ridiculously high new bounty might have
made less sense from the perspective of
the world governments but again as a
storytelling device it absolutely does
luffy had to surpass himself in every
possible way facing off against a
version of himself that was better than
him at everything and so it does feel
really deserved to us and to me really
hammered home luffy's achievement on
whole cake island overall so after all
this the strongest creature in the world
is now standing in front of luffy with a
bounty of 4.6 billion berries three
times that of luffy just as was the case
with crocodile as we discussed after
defeating an enemy luffy has always
surpassed them so if we assume that
luffy's bounty increases by roughly 333
percent like in alabasta that would
round up very nicely to 5 billion
berries however since we're talking
about luffy's final bounty in the story
i think he surely has to surpass roger
as well and the hint here are wordplace
huda loves his word place especially
with the yonko bounties shanks bounty
has shanks in it
kaido has the 100 beasts in it yakuzu
big mom has mom in hers haha whitebeard
has shiro in it as in white shirohige
and rodgers simply spells rojia and so
going with this pattern and the pattern
of luffy's bounty so far i am gonna
predict that luffy's final bounty in the
story will be 5 billion
656 million berries gomu gomu barely
surpassing roger himself and speaking of
the gomu gomi if you want to know what
luffy's awakening might be and why it's
already here go watch that video
right here right here it's no it's
actually oh it's here it's right here
right here that's where you watch the
video